a model takes a tumble as an iconic  angel takes her final walk down the  Victoria's Secret Fashion Show runway  [Music]  a lot went down literally on TVs sexiest  night  here's 28-year old Chinese model Ming Zi  slipping and falling during the 2017  Victoria's Secret Fashion Show being  recovered like a boss and got tons of  love from fellow model Lily Aldridge  you're so beautiful you look so  beautiful in and singer Leslie Odom jr.  sometimes we fall we get back up fall  down seven times get up baby  it was also a historic night for veteran  angel Alessandra Ambrosio after 17 years  the 36 year old strutted down the runway  for the last time she revealed the news  exclusively to ET this is it huh this  year of course you know I took goodbyes  and I'll be emotional but I'll have my  energy out there and I'll just you know  send out my love to everyone  [Applause]  [Music]